9 when people die everyday in America
from opioid drug overdoses in an
explosive joint investigation by 60
minutes and the Washington Post
whistleblowers tell bill Whittaker how
the drug industry with the help of
Congress turned an epidemic into a
full-blown crisis here's a preview of
Sunday's report this is an industry
that's that's out of control what they
want to do is do what they want to do
and not worry about what the law is and
if they don't follow the law in drug
supply people die that's just it people
die joe Rannazzisi is a tough blunt
former DEA deputy assistant
administrator with a law degree a
pharmacy degree and a smoldering rage at
the unrelenting death toll from opioids
his greatest ire is reserved for the
distributors some of them multi-billion
dollar fortune 500 companies they are
the middlemen that shipped the pain
pills from manufacturers like Purdue
Pharma and Johnson & Johnson to drug
stores all over the country Rena CC
accuses the distributors of fueling the
opioid epidemic by turning a blind eye
to pain pills being diverted to illicit
use this is an industry that allowed
millions and millions of drugs to go
into bad pharmacies and doctors offices
that distributed them out to people who
had no legitimate need for those drugs
who are these distributors the three
largest distributors are cardinal health
McKesson and Ameri source Bergen they
control probably 85 or 90 percent of the
drugs going downstream
you know the implication of what you're
saying that these big companies knew
that they were pumping drugs into
American communities that were killing
people that's not an implication that's
a fact
that's exactly what they did the
healthcare distribution Alliance
represents the drug distribution
companies it told 60 minutes they wanted
to work with the D
and that effective enforcement must be a
two-way street though Whitaker is here
along with Washington Post investigative
reporter Scott hi um good morning good
morning bill let me begin with this
exactly what was the those distributors
doing well the distributors are the
companies that ship the drugs from the
manufacturers to the pharmacies all
across the country they are required by
law to keep track of every single pill
they ship and they're also supposed to
alert the DEA of anything suspicious any
suspicious shipments an example one
small town in West Virginia of 390 some
people got shipments of 9 million opioid
pills over the course of a few years
that should have set off alarm bells
within the companies to tell the DEA
there's a problem here but the DEA
whistleblowers we talked to said that
happened again and again and again
Scott described your investigation it's
been more than a year in the making
right that's right Nora we began this
investigation about a year ago and it
was begun by a really dogged reporter at
the Washington Post by the name of Lenny
Bernstein and Lenny wanted to get
answers to a couple of key questions why
was so many people dying of opioid
epidemic of overdoses and where were all
these drugs coming from so he started
crashing the phones calling people and
he came across this guy named Joe
Rannazzisi who was a whistleblower at
the DEA he had been forced out of his
job and he ran a little office in the
DEA called the diversion Control
Division Lenny had never heard of it I
had never heard of it this is a group of
men and women very dedicated DEA
investigators who do nothing but
regulate the pharmaceutical industry and
pretty soon we started interviewing
other whistleblowers really amazing
people across the country who brought us
inside the opioid war between the DEA
and very powerful forces in Washington
DC and bill I'm sure you spoke to
lawmakers about this what was their
reaction we tried to speak to lawmakers
we did speak to some of them but the
whistleblowers we spoke to said that the
drug industry was so powerful so wealthy
so influential during the course of the
debate over the bill they pumped a
hundred six million dollars into
lobbying Congress on the bill and on
other legislation and the sponsors of
the bills got campaign contributions
some of them more than a hundred
thousand dollars and the whistle blowers
told us that they thought the influence
of the drug companies was more
influential than the suffering of their
constituents what did you hear from the
lawmakers well we heard we tried again
and again and again to get to the
sponsors of the bills we called them for
months we actually went to their offices
in Washington DC and in one instance had
the door shut in our face we were not
able to get to the sponsors of the bill
to hear what they had to say I mean the
implication Scott is not only did people
know about it but that they were
complicit in it because they were
profiting from these opioid addictions
and deaths quite frankly that's right
these DEA people that we spoke to knew
who were out in the field they were
building these cases they were seeing
people die left and right hundreds of
millions of pills coming into these
communities and they would build these
cases they would sit them to Washington
DC and they would just die on the vine
and they didn't understand what was
going on why their cases couldn't get
through Washington and then they started
to realize that there was a lot of
lobbying going on there were a lot of
people who used to work at the DEA and
Department of Justice who were lobbying
their former colleagues at DEA and
justice and their cases just languished
this is finally I feel like putting a
face on why is this happening why is
this happening you know I mean I
question that simple question it's
because if you're you know you're
explaining it in this investigation in
fact Scott you said this is a swampies
thing you've ever seen and then your
investigative career well you know at
the height of the worst drug crisis in
this country for Congress to pass a law
that hobbles the DA's efforts to rein in
this epidemic is just it takes your
breath away
has promised to drain the swamp we'll
see if the administration can address
this issue
thank you Bill thank you Scott thank you
guys you can see the full investigation
into what's behind the opioid epidemic
in Sunday's edition of The Washington
Post and on Sunday night's 60 minutes
right here on CBS